[Musique]
moi nous
bien dit monsieur les affaires ont l'air
de marcher que d'argent
[Musique]
oui
tiens c'est nouveau ça on remplace et
parcomètres par des machines à sous
enfin voilà une idée
[Musique]
bonjour ma famille soit
pauvre tonton tu vois tu as tout perdu
[Musique]
oh non tonton soit tout à part comment
sais tu sais bien qu'il n'ya pas de
chansons jeux
et voilà encore perdu ballack en live et
à voter la loi pourrait enfin c'est pas
dur pour tout le monde
cayrol
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au nom ton soit c'est de la folie
tu as truyen et
[Musique]
tu vois qu est-ce que je t'avais dit tu
n'as plus qu'à sous
[Musique]
ça va promener credo chiens non tonton
soit tout à tout de même pas vendre
credo chien mais il le fait et tout ça
pour aller jouer oui credo chien est
égal à cannes s'était échappé d'une
entorse attendons de voir
[Musique]
quoi toi tout est quelque chose on a
besoin de toi
[Applaudissements]
pis aller il faut retrouver credo chez
nous on n'est pas là sinon plus le voilà
[Musique]
tout autant rachète credo chien le run
en range tendance voire veut racheter
craintes au chien il n'est plus la même
mais s'est pas créé de ciel il est tombé
sur une échelle il a reçu d'appels tueur
menteur voilà credo chien
[Applaudissements]
commençons par supprimer des jeux
d'argent dont confiera moins tentés de
faire des bêtises
quant à toi gros soir attend un peu
regardera plus mesdames et messieurs les
jeux sont faits au revoir à tous à tous
et merci
tous
et
oh